do you find that as feminists like get
older like they can get away with less
stuff is that like a thing do you think
yeah I think you know as the red pillars
like to say once you hit that wall or
once you approach the wall it's really
hard to it's really it's very
unforgiving right so like you know in
your 20s you probably get away with more
you probably get away with more like
craziness you get away with more like in
relationships and in dating and then
once you hit
especially like your later 20s to your
early 30s I would say some women like to
push that to like
late 30s
um
you kind of start realizing or hopefully
coming to terms with the fact that
life's not how you were playing it for a
while